[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débats et de
reportages sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
22 juin l'Ukraine est-elle en train
d'échouer dans sa contre-offensive c'est
trop tôt pour en juger affirme volo 2000
ski on n'est pas à Hollywood où tout se
règle en quelques minutes dit le
président ukrainien peut-il espérer
percer profondément la ligne de front
que change l'attaque contre un pont
stratégique de Crimée pourquoi l'Ukraine
et ses alliés parlent déjà de
reconstruction depuis hier à Londres
alors que la guerre est loin d'être
terminée on répond à ces questions juste
après les titres et puis à Paris depuis
ce matin c'est le défi de la dette et du
climat qu'Emmanuel Macron et plus de 60
chefs d'État et de gouvernement relèvent
entendu beaucoup de décideurs ces
derniers mois parfois ces dernières
années très souvent dire au fond vous
nous expliquez vous qui avez déjà réglé
le problème de la pauvreté ce qu'il
faudrait faire en matière de transition
climatique elle est les choix qu'on
devrait prendre mais nous nous n'avons
pas encore réglé le problème de la
pauvreté que peut-on attendre ceux de ce
sommet Nord-Sud pour un nouveau pacte
financier mondial combien de milliards
de dollars faut-il mobiliser pour sauver
les pays les plus pauvres qui sont aussi
les plus impactés par le réchauffement
faut-il passer par de nouvelles taxes
sur les activités les plus polluantes on
en débat dans trois quarts d'heure mais
d'abord les dernières nouvelles en
provenance du front ukrainien le
président zellenski admet tout de même
que les progrès sont moins rapides que
prévu Jérôme Rabier l'on sait depuis le
4 juin la contre-offensive ukrainienne
semble patiner malgré le peu
d'informations communiquées par
l'état-major ukrainien le président
zellenski a reconnu hier que les progrès
était plus long qu'espérée même tonalité
chez son premier ministre aujourd'hui
cela pourrait prendre du temps mais nous
avons l'intention d'aller de l'avant
nous allons de l'avant avec la
contrefensive nous devons tous faire
preuve de patience et nous verrons des
résultats
si l'avancée
la ligne de front les Ukrainiens
subissent de lourdes pertes et doivent
regrouper leurs troupes assure le
Kremlin Vladimir Poutine ironisant sur
la question
curieusement en ce moment nous observons
un certain calme sur le front cela est
dû au fait que l'ennemi subit de graves
pertes en personnel et en équipement
si sur le front seuls quelques rares
localités ont été libérées les frappes
se concentrent sur l'arrière dans les
zones tenues par les Russes cette nuit
impose stratégique qui relie la Crimée
au sud du pays a été bombardé mais côté
ukrainien on redoute une nouvelle
catastrophe après la destruction du
ouvrage proche de Kerson mais cette fois
à la centrale nucléaire de zapporica
proche de la ligne de front
le service de renseignement ont reçu des
informations selon lesquelles la Russie
envisage le scénario d'un acte
terroriste à la centrale nucléaire de
vaporidja un attentat avec un rejet de
radiation ils ont tout préparé à cet
effet des accusations rejetées par
Moscou qui voit une diversion pour
cacher l'échec de la contre-offensive
mais cette dernière ne ferait que
commencer face à des forces russes
désormais mieux fortifiées l'état-major
ukrainien prévient qu'il faudra s'armer
de patience la contre-offensive
l'attaque du pont de Tsonga en Crimée
mais aussi cette conférence
internationale sur la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine qui se tient déjà à Londres
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder avec mes
invités le général Christophe gomard
bonsoir merci c'est un chef du
renseignement militaire à lazareva
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi rectrice
en chef adjointe du journal
Ukraine ski Tidiane c'est le seul
journal U avoir lancé une page en
français co-auteur de ce livre Gazprom
nouvelle empire paru aux éditions les
petits matins Florent Parmentier bonsoir
bon bienvenue aussi vous êtes secrétaire
général du CVP Sciences Po et chercheurs
associés au centre de géopolitique de
HEC Laetitia cru pas bonsoir Laetitia
bienvenue à vous alors on démarre
évidemment par cette contre-offensive
général Goma est-ce que elle est moins
rapide que prévu est-ce que ça vous
surprend ça non je ne suis pas surpris
c'est à dire que je pense que les les
Ukrainiens ont attaqué en trois endroits
du front sans doute chercher t-il un
endroit où les la Défense russe était
plus faible et où le front russe était
moins épais j'allais dire plus facile à
franchir
la guerre ça dure longtemps ça ne se
fait pas comme ça c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui ils doivent en effet
effectuer une pause opérationnelle au
cours de laquelle ils vont se
réarticuler pour sans doute réattaquer
ailleurs ça n'a pas percé cette fois-ci
ça passera peut-être une autre fois on
voit bien que le président vole ce qui
dit que il faut la patience oui il faut
la patience à la guerre rien ne se fait
aussi rapidement qu'on peut l'espérer
mais est-ce que ces alliés ont peut-être
manqué de patience est-ce qu'il a pas
aussi déclenché cette offensive sous
pression c'est une vraie question c'est
est-ce que il a déclenché déclenché
cette offensive en disant aux Alliés qui
leur donnent qui lui fournissent du
matériel voilà regardez je fais des
choses je tente des choses vis-à-vis de
sa propre population également qui est
assez remonté et qui veut qui veut la
victoire
donc oui il a été poussé à ça la période
était plus haut et bonne parce qu'en
fait c'était la c'était le printemps de
début de l'été donc le sol est sec c'est
plus facile de se déplacer donc en fait
tout concourrait à ce qu'il attaque à ce
moment-là est-ce qu'il a est-ce qu'il
était présomptueux vis-à-vis de ses
propres forces je ne le pense pas
maintenant les Russes ont eu six mois en
effet pour créer si une de front ou 5
lignes de fonds différentes ils se sont
j'allais dire face à leur échec initial
et se renforcés en termes de drone ils
sont renforcés en termes de Galles
électronique se renforcer dans beaucoup
de domaines
mais ce sont préparés à cette attaque à
cette offensive à la Lazare c'est faut
parler des mines son principalement les
mines qui ralentissent les soldats
Ukrainiens exactement oui c'est les
conclusions de plusieurs experts
militaires et donc ceux qui sont
expriment régulièrement dans notre média
en fait le plus grand problème c'est les
mines parce que l'armée russe renforçant
leur position ils ont miné très très
largement il continue de le faire elles
ont l'équipement pour et il manque pas
des mines tant que tels donc c'est vrai
que les Ukrainiens sont obligés de
avancer très très prudemment bon
les forces n'est pas sacrifiée nos
soldats à coriandre et c'est vrai que ça
prend du temps donc notre chef
d'état-major il dit que on ne fonce pas
les barrages on les défait brique par
briques
pardon juste une question parce que
comme vous dites les militaires nous
disent que vous avez des liens directs
avec le chef d'état-major qui vous parle
à la presse ukrainienne il parle pas
souvent la presse ukrainienne mais ça
arrive il fait les conférences de presse
très peu très très peu mais ça arrive
Florent Parmentier je parlais de la
pressions l'état-major et qui
travaillaient à notre journal donc aussi
vous avez les sources et les remontées
d'informations
donc j'étais en train de Florent
parmentier de dire il y a cette pression
des amis mais il y a aussi une sorte de
pression notre pression à nous
journalistes pignons publics à attendre
cette fallait spéculation autour de la
contre-offensive elle durer depuis
tellement longtemps que là on voudrait
que ça on voudrait que ça il y a toute
vitesse quoi il y a aussi ça dans le
dans le dans le regard qu'on porte sur
ces trois dernières semaines il y a
probablement effectivement le rôle de
volody merzelinski qui est celui qui a
eu depuis maintenant le début de la
guerre qui est celui de gérer des
attentes il doit durer des attentes qui
sont parfois contradictoires ils
attendent de ce opinion publique les
attentes de ces alliés les attentes
également de ses propres enfin l'opinion
publique internationale les attentes de
ces allées c'est important c'est tout
simplement en fonction de l'avancée de
la contre-offens arrive il est probable
que il est probable reste à voir mais en
tout cas que le type d'attente le type
de concession que l'Ukraine pour obtenir
lors du prochain sommet de l'OTAN à
Vilnius changeront à la marge pas
nécessairement de manière radicale mais
en tout cas il y a de ce point de vue là
de la part de même travail qui est fait
depuis maintenant plus d'un an qui est
de convaincre les opinions publiques et
les gouvernants extérieurs ces alliés
européens américains que ça vaut la
peine d'envoyer des armes à l'Ukraine
maintenant et que tout autre solution
qui serait une forme de PC pareil une
forme d'armistice une forme de conflit
gelée en fait n'entre pas dans
l'équation en tout cas notre ni dans son
équation ni un sel de l'opinion publique
c'est l'enjeu des prochaines semaines
avant ce sommet de l'OTAN avideusif il
faut qu'il donne des gages en quelque
sorte qu'ils fournissent les armes
depuis depuis
un public auprès de ses alliés tout
simplement parce que dans quelques mois
les États-Unis seront dans une autre
dimension politique ils seront sur des
élections euh
présidentielle et que dans ces élections
présidentielles on peut s'attendre à ce
qui est au moins des passes d'armes
sinon des formes de questionnements donc
on sera dans une autre dynamique peuvent
revenir sur leurs engagements vis-à-vis
de l'Ukraine ou pas dans cette
période-là que vous décrivez a priori
non si on pense que c'est le président
Biden qui s'est engagé et qu'il a une
majorité dans son système politique pour
le faire mais cela pourrait
néanmoinsérer les futurs promesses qui
pourraient être faites ne serait-ce que
par une forme d'attentisme et puis tout
simplement parce qu'on ne venait pas
encore le candidat du côté des
républicains mais que beaucoup de
discussions existent du côté de la
République un peu plus tard parce qu'on
va consacrer un chapitre de de débat
justement à l'OTAN et aux espoirs de
l'Ukraine d'intégrer l'OTAN à dire
plutôt moyen terme à propos de cette
contre-offensive je vous propose une
première réaction celle du Premier
ministre ukrainien de Nice schmigal
comme l'a dit hier le président
ukrainien la contre-offensive ce n'est
pas un film hollywoodien ce n'est pas un
travail facile la contre-offensive c'est
un certain nombre d'opérations
militaires parfois offensive parfois
défensive parfois cela peut être des
postes tactiques
malheureusement lors de notre
préparation pour cette contre-offensive
les Russes se préparer aussi
donc ils ont mis en place énormément de
champs de mines qui ralentissent
vraiment notre progression alors cet
argument du film hollywoodien je l'ai
pris moi dans les titres c'était volumes
et ainsi qu'il a dit la première fois et
ça parle à l'opinion occidentale on
reconnaisse son sens de la communication
mais je voudrais général Gomar qu'on
parle finalement quand on est souvent
dans des débats on parle stratégie on
parle des armes livrées et comme il y a
assez peu de chiffres sur les morts et
les blessés on l'évoque assez peu est-ce
que c'est une guerre dévastatrice en ce
moment je pense que il y a toute une
génération de jeunes
oui qui ont été tués d'une part et
d'autres qui ont été blessés et qui
psychologiquement seront très marqués
pour les autres donc ça va marquer très
durablement cette génération j'ai dire
entre 20 à 20 et 30 ans combien de morts
il y en a je ne sais pas je ne serai pas
dire je pense qu'en terme de blessé et
de tuer on est à plusieurs centaines de
milliers parce que vu le nombre d'obus
qui sont tirés depuis le départ depuis
18 mois ça occasionne des morts beaucoup
plus que les tirs directs que l'on voit
avec les fusils ont été où les tirs de
chars qui sont parfois utilisés comme
des canons d'artillerie donc il y a
beaucoup d'obus qui ont été utilisés à
tel point c'est que le vrai sujet souci
les Occidentaux c'est la livraison de
munitions mais les Occidentaux en fait
ne produisent pas suffisamment de
munitions pour répondre aux besoins
réels de l'Ukraine alors que côté des
Russes ils ont d'abord une véritable
industrie d'armement ils avaient des
réserves en nombre qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
utilisé à tel point c'est quand même on
est on disait que les Russes utilisaient
20000 obus par jour et les Ukrainiens
5000 donc vous imaginez bien que 5000
obus par jour ou 20000 encore pire en
face à des trucs beaucoup de choses et
beaucoup de gens combien il y en aura à
la fin est-ce qu'on sort un jour mais
enfin je pense qu'on peut passer c'est
plusieurs dizaines de milliers voir de
ne pas communiquer parce que les
familles doivent forcément compter leurs
morts il est possible de normalement
comptabiliser le nombre de morts même
tous les jours et c'est une stratégie
certainement politique militaire de
guerre de ne pas bien évidemment d'abord
c'est pour le moral de la population
maintenant je pense que les services
occidentaux de regarder également avec
des images satellites aux images de
drones le nombre de cimetières c'est que
par la guerre Hugo Savy ont gardé le
nombre d'affiches qui étaient sur les
arbres pour annoncer les deuils en
réalité pour essayer de d'évaluer le
nombre de tués parce que c'est
extrêmement compliqué et qui dit le
nombre de tuer dit également j'allais
dire l'affaiblissement d'une armée
évidemment est-ce que on est capable de
mobiliser de recruter encore plus c'est
ça la vraie difficulté comment est-ce
qu'on engage des jeunes soldats que l'on
pendant trois mois trois mois c'est à
peine suffisant trois mois vous savez
utiliser votre arme et vous savez pas
faire la guerre donc oui il y a tout ce
temps et c'est pour ça qu'en fait il
faut pas démobiliser les gens voir faire
fuir les gens parce que certains veulent
échapper effectivement à la mobilisation
évidemment donc ça côté ukrainien comme
côté russe c'est-à-dire que des deux
côtés on passe le reste c'est à dire que
vous n'allez pas au combat sans avoir
sans avoir été préparé et on voit bien
travailler témoignages de journalistes
que ces soldats subissent énormément de
choses
et dans cette offensive ils ont eu
effectivement beaucoup de morts grâce
enfin à cause des mines plus exactement
des chars qui ont été détruits char
occidentaux comme char de conception
soviétique donc oui c'est très très dur
pour eux et la difficulté d'un président
comme vous le dit merci c'est de
mobiliser ces troupes j'allais dire de
les remotiver et on voit bien le
discours du premier ministre comme on
voit bien le sien enfin celui de
l'universalinsky parliez de la genèse
des soldats j'ai quand on parle de
l'Ukraine j'ai souvent en tête ce film à
l'ouest rien de nouveau
qui raconte la dernière alors
qu'évidemment adapté du livre de Joseph
Maria Rico si je ne me trompe qui
raconte la dernière année de la première
guerre mondiale avec une génération de
jeunes Allemands qui qui partent au
combat en pensant qu'ils vont marcher
sur Paris et puis qui découvre la guerre
le le premier jour avec des dizaines de
morts parmi eux et je pense que quand on
fait un débat sur le crâne faut jamais
oublier ça quoi c'est exactement c'est
important de le dire à lazarella est-ce
qu'il y a un tabou des morts et des
blessés en Ukraine justement pour
reprendre ce que disait qu'il faut avoir
pour ne pas démoraliser l'opinion non il
y a pas des tabous mais c'est vrai que
la chiffres exacts n'est pas connu pour
l'instant par contre quand on a dit au
revoir euros c'est toujours très
émouvant il y a tous les tous les gens
qui passent et ils se mettent au genou
aussi donc il y a cette série qui se
sont formés pendant cette guerre pour
dire merci sur le front ou quand il y a
des morts qui reviennent
d'enterrement en fait c'est très
impressionnant aussi c'est tous les
toute la rue des gens qui est juste qui
passent qui rencontre donc en fait la
précieuse procession donc funèbre il se
met à de mes genoux comme ça et pour
dire au revoir dernière fois donc à
quelqu'un que nous défend donc je dis
pas qu'il y a un tabou on en parle
beaucoup
il y a je pense qu'il y a pas de village
de ville le plus petit village qui n'a
pas perdu au moins une personne tout le
monde connaît autour de nous quelqu'un
qui est parti pour moi c'est les enfants
de mes amis qui sont qui étaient tués
plusieurs donc c'est c'est extrêmement
douloureux c'est la génération de des
gamins qu'on a vu naître et c'est tout
le pays comme ça on peut pas cacher
cette vérité et c'est ce que disait
généralement c'est une génération
sacrifiée dont on peut parler parmi les
faits marquants de ces dernières heures
on en a vu furtivement une image dans le
dans le sujet de de Jérôme Rabier il y a
ce cette frappe contre un pont donc le
pont de Tsonga c'est un édifice
important qui relie la Crimée annexée
une région du sud de l'Ukraine qui est
partiellement occupée par les forces
russes les images que l'on regarde sont
des images qu'on était publié
aujourd'hui sur un compte télégramme
d'un responsable installé par Moscou
dans la région de Carson voilà c'est
toujours important d'avoir la la source
Florent Parmentier ce pont c'est quoi
c'est un axe stratégique il est
important qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire
je pense qu'il faut remettre la
destructions de son pont dans le
contexte plus global va contresensive ou
il y a trois éléments d'analyse qu'il
faut observer le premier c'est les
démonstratégiques dans une
contre-offensive il y avait la question
de quand elle avait commencé cette
contre-offensive qui nous a occupés
pendant plusieurs mois mais il y a aussi
la question de l'effet de surprise jouer
sur quand ou quoi finalement c'est un
moyen de pour l'américaine de préparer
sa contre-offensive en essayant d'avoir
un espèce de brouillard à partir
desquels elle pourrait faire les choses
là effectivement est-ce que l'armée
russe a suffisait en protéger ce pont la
réponse semble être non le deuxième
élément important au-delà de l'aspect
stratégique c'est l'aspect militaire et
l'aspect militaire ça on le verra c'est
à mon sens la question de l'intégration
des nouvelles armes que les Ukrainiens
ont pu recevoir ou celles qui sont en
passe de recevoir avec toute une
question qui est celle qui est celle de
l'aviation est-ce qu'on peut faire une
attaque avec des blindés face aux
défenses russes sans avoir une sorte de
domination aérienne c'est une question
en fait qui doit se poser à peu près
aujourd'hui dans toutes les écoles de
guerre tout simplement parce qu'on n'a
pas eu d'expérience précédente dans une
guerre de haute intensité en Europe
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a toujours eu
l'aviation un rôle primordial
on était sur ce domaine très précis où
on était sur des guerres intégrées dans
les tranchées on a l'impression
effectivement de ce point de vue là ça
sonne étrangement similaire parce qu'en
réalité on ne voit pas les avions
effectivement au-dessus et les as des as
de la Première Guerre mondiale avait un
rôle de reconnaissance un peu comme des
drones aujourd'hui donc on a ces enjeux
là ce qu'on peut dire sur ce pont c'est
tout simplement voilà que aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine a malgré tout l'armée
ukrainienne a intégré un certain nombre
d'armes qui lui permettent de est-ce que
elle a les armes aujourd'hui et
l'intégration de ces armes qui lui
permettent de tirer avantage de ce type
de points ça c'est un élément encore
qu'on ne sait pas qui sera j'allais dire
à l'origine de le succès ou non de la
contre-offensive troisième élément
évidemment le l'élément politique il y a
la fois une question dans cette guerre
de on parlait du nombre de morts qui
voilà il y a des sondages aujourd'hui
qui disent en substance compte je crois
qu'il y a un article d'une
qui disait lors d'un sondage c'est un
journal ukrainien il y a Kiev qui disait
en substance
37% des
Ukrainiens connaissent soit un ami soit
un membre de la famille donc un ami
proche de la famille qui est décédé au
cours de ce conflit ça paraît
considérable je ne sais pas si le
chiffre est vérifiable je viens de le
dire aussi je pense qu'il est
malheureusement assez
crédible crédible vraisemblable
mais ce qu'il faut observer c'est que
malgré tout la cohésion et le moral
l'enjeu psychologique de cette guerre du
côté de la population en Ukraine est à
peu est assez remarquable plus de 90%
des Ukrainiens sont persuadés que le
conflit se remporté par l'Ukraine et 50%
à peu près pensent que ce sera dès cette
année 25% et c'est à peu près dans les
deux à trois ans donc on va malgré tout
que ce type d'image
spectaculaire s'est envoyé aussi un
message à l'opinion publique qui
consiste à dire qu'on est capable de les
taper même en Crimée côté ukrainien là
c'est sondage côté russe est-ce qu'on a
enfin vous voyez ce que je veux dire
est-ce que Poutine a besoin de sonder
son opinion
il a forcément besoin son opinion ne
serait-ce que pour savoir si il peut
mobiliser dans quelle mesure ils peuvent
user ou il a besoin de savoir si il peut
mobiliser à tel endroit ce qui peut
mobiliser à Moscou et à
Saint-Pétersbourg visiblement non mais
il peut me viser dans des républiques
centraliatiques beaucoup plus largement
oui donc il est obligé malgré tout de
tenir ce type de la vie des jeunes qui
il est malgré tout obligé de tenir
compte des mouvements d'opinion publique
et je
j'évoque à ce titre l'ouvrage récemment
publié par Sergio greffief spin dictator
qui dit en substance et bien que venir
Poutine tient c'est comment manipuler
son opinion alors dans le cas de ayant
Ukraine il y a une régression assez
violente on part de quelque chose qui
est plutôt de la manipulation globale à
de plus en plus de j'allais dire de
d'autoritarisme mais mais en tout cas en
tout cas sur les 20 dernières années au
pouvoir où les années précédent la
guerre en Ukraine oui
il en tient compte un mot je reste je
reviens sur ce sur ce pont pour entendre
votre avis
Gérald Goma c'est quoi c'est une route
de ravitaillement c'est il y en a
d'autres qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en dire oui il y en a d'autres mais
dès que vous cassez un pont ou un axe
c'est très très gênant sur plan
logistique à la guerre ce qui compte
avant tout c'est la logistique c'était
la capacité à renforcer le front à
ramener des munitions des vivres pour
les saladescendants à ramener des
véhicules neufs ou réparés donc oui
c'est absolument essentiel c'est bien
pour ça qu'en fait depuis le départ on
voit bien que chacun cherche à détruire
chez l'autre des points de
ravitaillement logistique des sites de
carburant des dépôts logistiques en au
sens large donc oui un pont c'est
crucial et on voit bien sur le diep tous
les ponts ont été cassés donc pour
pourquoi pour empêcher les armées
respectives de franchir ce niep qui est
pas en droit et là j'ai plusieurs
kilomètres donc oui tapez un pont c'est
quelque chose de très très fort de la
part des Ukrainiens et c'est très gênant
pour les Russes on va parler avec vous
Laetitia du chef de la milice Wagner je
crois que à chaque fois qu'on fait un
débat on peut consacrer un chapitre et
gagner prioriologie parce qu'il prend la
parole régulièrement et continue de
communiquer contre la hiérarchie
militaire russe il pourrait devenir
quand même pour pouvoir les murs Poutine
un handicap oui c'est plus un caillot de
la chaussure à ce stade c'est un boulet
pour Vladimir Poutine mais déjà on
parlait là de propagande on parlait
d'opinion publique il y a aussi cet
enjeu quand même pour Vladimir Poutine
et si Briger une parvient à toucher
l'opinion publique russe là et il va
vraiment sacrément se mettre en travers
de chef du Kremlin donc il dit tout
simplement dans toutes ces
communications un quasiment Poutine vous
ment Poutine
est-ce qu'ici le président en tout cas
c'est le fond effectivement de ces
interventions il a communiqué deux fois
déjà cette semaine alors ça a commencé
mardi avec un communiqué de presse il
fait ça dans les règles de l'art c'est
son bureau de presse qui envoie un
communiqué à tous les organes de presse
et tout les médias internationaux donc
vous voyez il a carrément organisé une
structure autour de lui pour communiquer
à l'occidental finalement et ce
communiqué de presse a touché mais les
médias occidentaux par exemple sur
Twitter le Jérusalem post a tweeté après
la réception de ce communiqué on peut
dire en titre Prigogine se plaint que
ces soldats n'ont pas reçu les médailles
promise par la Russie oui et c'est
effectivement l'objet de ce communiqué
de presse priori fustige les autorités
russes d'avoir oublié ses soldats après
la bataille de barmut alors que Poutine
aurait promis de les récompenser et dans
son communiqué par exemple il dit selon
mes informations il y a une agitation
autour des récompenses tout le monde a
déjà oublié que mes hommes ont combattu
et sont morts là-bas donc lui parle de
mort hier il a recommencé avec un
message cette fois mais ça joue audio
sur télégram Oui c'est un message assez
long où il détaille les pertes russes
justement lui parle de perte russe il
dit que c'est tous les jours depuis le
début de la offensive ukrainienne et on
sait que le chef de la musique Wagner
est en guerre ouverte avec les autorités
russes et la Hiéra sanitaire et puis
aussi le ministre de la Défense et que
finalement Vladimir Poutine le laisse
faire c'est un peu le Fou du roi parce
que ça permet à Poutine de faire
pression sur son ministre de la Défense
mais c'est un jeu dangereux parce que
prigogène voit de plus en plus loin
communication après communication hier
dans son message audio par exemple il
dit il y a de sérieuses pertes et des
problèmes étouffés que les Russes ne
savent pas
complètement caché à tout le monde un
jour la Russie se réveillera et
s'apercevra que la Crimée est
ukrainienne c'est une trahison directe
des intérêts de la Fédération de Russie
ou encore autre passage tout ce que fait
le commandement de l'opération militaire
spéciale aujourd'hui c'est cacher les
faits pour rendre à Moscou de beaux
rapports et tromper le peuple rousse
donc vous voyez bien le peuple russe
Huawei est bien tout l'enjeu c'est à
dire que si ce peuple russe prend
connaissance et a déjà connaissance de
ces messages nombreux qui sont diffusés
sur sur les réseaux sociaux il va
falloir voir comment ce peuple russe
réagit est-ce qu'il va se retourner
contre Vladimir Poutine ou pas c'est une
vraie question à la lazareva que sait-on
de l'effet de ces diatribles de
trigognes sur l'opinion russe sur le
pignon de russe c'est quand même très
difficile à évaluer parce que c'est très
opaque chez eux et la sociologie n'est
pas disons la sociologie publique
serait faire uniquement aux données que
les gens veulent communiquer donc les
réponses qu'ils donnent est-ce qu'ils
sont vraiment sincères est-ce qu'ils
disent vraiment ce qu'il pense donc
c'est vraiment apprendre avec beaucoup
de précautions en même temps bon on
présente en Ukraine que si Prigogine n'a
pas de contrat avec les services secrets
ukrainiennes et il est en train de le
saigner quoi parce que effectivement il
affaiblit le camp militaire russe donc
après avec quel objectif aussi ça se
peut qu'il veut remplacer poutine au
pouvoir il se sera meilleur
et pour l'Ukraine et pour la Russie et
pour le monde entier c'est peut-être non
pareil donc voilà c'est c'est assez
difficile à évaluer stratégiquement mais
en gros quand chaque fois quand je sème
les doutes chez la population de russe
qui n'a pas l'habitude de douter c'est
peut-être pas d'être alors on a consacré
un débat il y a quelques jours au
ministre Wagner enfin au groupe Wagner
d'ailleurs c'est enfin voilà c'est
empire économique on va pas trop
redétayer ça mais est-ce que votre avis
là est-ce qu'il devient si puissant
qu'il peut presque tout se permettre
priori donc pour moi frigozy je pense et
reste en lien fort avec Poutine en
revanche il parle au peuple russe
c'est-à-dire qu'il va le dire au peuple
russe la vérité les citations que vous
avez montré l'indique il dit au peuple
russe en fait avec à limite en
mobilisant le peuple
océan de le mobiliser contre le fait
qu'on ne dit pas tout et qu'il faut
savoir que la si par exemple me dit la
Crimée va devenir ukrainienne on va dire
c'est pas possible la Crimée peut pas
redevenir ukrainienne donc oui en fait
il y a
[Musique]
quel est son autre son autre capital la
main d'oeuvre faut qu'il ait
suffisamment de combattants d'où les
questions de les petits encore recrutés
dans les prisons aussi facilement par le
passé etc sa question de son bassin de
recrutement quelque sorte et un autre un
autre élément troisième élément il est
là aussi pour capter le maximum de
ressources financières mais aussi de
ressources en termes d'armement d'où
c'est diatribles récurrentes au moment
de la bataille de barmut on ne m'a pas
livré assez d'armes en réalité quand on
regardait il avait assez d'armes donc
c'est pas ça qui était en jeu ça casse
sa capacité absolue et qu'il diffuse
vous imaginez le choc des images si le
film les morts c'est mort qu'on ne voit
pas c'est mort qu'on cache ses morts
qu'on donnait des nombres même pas et il
a fait d'ailleurs
effectivement
mais pour moi là-dessus là aussi il faut
savoir à qui s'adresse il s'adresse une
partie à ses clients internationales
c'est ce qui est internationaux si on
regarde à qui s'adresse en Russie je
pense que beaucoup ont fait le
constat de l'opinion publique il y a il
y a des restes de cor
considérable et donc j'ai inventé une
personnage une personne incorruptible
entre guillemets c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui est absolument sans concession qui
permet effectivement de regarder parce
qu'en réalité qu'est-ce qui s'était
passé avec le muscva ce navire amiral de
la flotte russe qui était coulée un peu
plus d'un an et bien c'est que tout
simplement les systèmes électroniques
qui devaient être remplacés n'ont pas
été remplacées et un coup de peinture
qui a été mis et ça a été facturé au
prix de la remise à niveau de l'ensemble
du système donc la corruption je pense
que les Russes sont suffisamment au
courant du de pour voir que ça n'a pas
changé que ça pose des problèmes donc
l'idée est de dire voilà ça permet ce
que ce qu'on dit il y a un proverbe
russe il dit en substance il y a
plusieurs tours au Kremlin c'est à dire
que le dépositaire du Kremlin il
maîtrise peut-être pas l'ensemble du
processus mais il doit être sûr parfois
de jouer une turc contre l'autre de
manière à pouvoir avancer dans certaines
années on parle de l'OTAN je propose à
terme traduit de me rejoindre tout de
suite sur sur ce plateau bonsoir Tam on
l'a évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure on
est à un mois du sommet de Vilnius et
l'Ukraine veut plus que jamais adhérer à
l'OTAN et c'est ce qu'a réaffirmé au
début du mois de juin au
ères devant par terre de leaders
européen qui a été réuni en Moldavie
voilà ces mots tous les pays européens
qui ont une frontière avec la Russie et
qui ne veulent pas que la Russie leur
arrache une partie de leur territoire
doivent être membres à part entière de
l'OTAN et de l'Union européenne c'est la
son argumentation c'est là son
avertissement alors l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN ce n'est pas un sujet
nouveau loin de là en 2008 déjà lors du
sommet de Bucarest le sujet et débattu
un accord de principe est consenti mais
sans aucun calendrier contraignant car
alors et bien les Occidentaux ne sont
pas tous sur la même ligne d'un côté
vous avez les États-Unis qui sont
favorables à l'entrée de l'Ukraine c'est
alors l'administration bouche et puis
vous avez Paris et Berlin Nicolas
Sarkozy et Angela Merkel qui au
contraire sont opposés et mettent leur
véto et d'ailleurs le président
ukrainien il l'a bien en mémoire ah ça
c'est très clair le président ukrainien
on veut encore à l'ex-président de la
République en veut encore Alex
chancelière allemande l'année dernière
après la découverte du massacre de bout
cha voilà ce que dit volody mirzelinski
j'invite Madame Merkel et Monsieur
Sarkozy a visité bout de chat et voir à
quoi la politique de concession à la
Russie a abouti en 14 ans voilà ne pas
provoquer la Russie en voici les
conséquences selon lui et cela a été
d'ailleurs longtemps la position de la
France et de l'Allemagne de ne pas
provoquer la Russie et au mois de
décembre dernier encore et bien Emmanuel
Macron avait exactement la même
argumentation dans un entretien en monde
il disait l'entrée de l'Ukraine dans
l'OTAN serait perçue par la Russie comme
quelque chose de confrontationnel ce
n'est pas avec cette Russie là que vous
pouvez l'imaginer est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron aurait évolué quand même dans sa
position et bien oui on a l'impression
qu'il y a une véritable volte-face est
une information du monde le 12 juin lors
du Conseil de défense l'Élysée s'est
converti à l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'OTAN c'est la position de la Pologne
déjà c'est la position des pays baltes
reste que bien sûr hors de question que
l'Ukraine rejoigne l'OTAN tant que dure
la guerre en raison de l'article 5 du
Traité de l'Atlantique Nord défini la
solidarité automatique avec un État
membre agressé faire entrer un pays en
guerre dans l'OTAN c'est entre soi-même
dans la guerre et de son côté bien Joe
Biden lui a bien déclaré qu'il n'y
aurait aucun traitement de faveur pour
faciliter l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'OTAN merci beaucoup Tam traduit pour
toutes ces informations on reste
quelques minutes sur le temps et puis
ensuite le temps a filé vraiment vite on
va on va parler de ce sommet de la
reconstruction cette conférence
internationale à Londres à la lazareva
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important
aujourd'hui je vais lier ça au processus
d'entrée dans l'Union européenne c'est
de d'intégrer l'OTAN ou l'Union
européenne qu'est-ce qui prend le plus
le voilà de de j'allais dire de de place
dans dans les interrogations des
Ukrainiens dans les médias dans la
communication de du chef de l'État
européenne parce que avec le temps on a
la collaboration qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui vu qu'on a
nous sommes un état en guerre des hautes
étanité et c'est clair que le temps ne
peut pas très rapidement intégré un état
qui a une guerre
totale c'est oblige tout de suite à
rentrer en guerre tous les autres donc
je ne pense pas que tous les
dirigeants de des pays de l'OTAN sont
prêts par contre l'Union européenne
c'est beaucoup plus réaliste et c'est
peut-être aussi beaucoup plus important
pour la reconstruction et pour l'avenir
de l'Ukraine donc je pense que oui on
estime que c'est globalement on estime
que c'est plus important mais on a
appris aujourd'hui que alors c'était une
information je crois orale l'Ukraine
remplit deux des sept conditions posées
pour une entrée dans l'Union européenne
Florent Parmentier si on respecte le
processus tel qu'il existe depuis des
années ça mettra je crois peut-être une
décennie sauf s'il y a une volonté
politique très forte c'est c'est la
question elle est là la question
effectivement est que les pays des
Balkans ont eu un sommet en 2003 on
mettait Salonique dans lequel il était
promis de pouvoir faire de
l'élargissement ensuite ces
élargissements ils sont de nature
technique naturellement mais aussi de
nature politique
au-delà de la question du est-ce qu'on
est membre de l'Union européenne est-ce
que on reste à la porte indéfiniment et
la question aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
des de l'adhésion
j'allais dire
le terme en anglais stage accession mais
ce qui correspond en quelque sorte d'une
forme d'intégration par palier ou
progressive pour dire vous êtes déjà
membre de tels et tel politique dès
maintenant c'est à dire que le processus
est enclenché symboliquement on dira
voilà on a enclenché le processus vous
êtes déjà avec nous sur certaines
distances effectivement des durées
prolongées sur un certain nombre de
points d'ailleurs se souvenir que lors
de l'élargissement de 2004 pour s'y
concerner par exemple la possibilité de
travailler au sein d'Union Européenne il
y a eu un certain nombre de délais qui
ont été accordés aux états de manière à
ce qu'ils puissent
s'adapter sur un certain nombre de
points et même chose du côté des
États-Unis donc ça fera partie d'une
négociation compliquée puisque
naturellement la taille de l'Ukraine
l'ampleur des enjeux de négociations et
l'ampleur des enjeux de la
reconstruction et bien tout cela fera
finalement que nous serons dans un
processus forcément qui prendra
plusieurs années alors justement la
reconstruction cette conférence
internationale sur la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine qui est une ligne soixantaine
de pays à Londres tiens je vous propose
d'écouter la vice-ministre ukrainienne
d'un des communautés des territoires et
du développement des infrastructures
elle s'appelle Alexandra azarkina
les besoins Ukrainiens annoncés dans le
rapport de la Banque mondiale sont là et
nous comprenons que pour atteindre ce
montant d'argent nous avons besoin des
Russes pour payer les donateurs comme
vous le savez s'attendent pas être
soutenu et à un moment donné nous avons
besoin que les Russes paient leur
économie continue de fonctionner de
travailler de croître il faut juste
qu'elle s'arrête à un moment donné et
qu'elle paie vraiment pour ce qu'elle a
fait
la capacité de faire payer la Russie
mais d'ailleurs j'ai une question très
concrète à la réserver est-ce que la
reconstruction a déjà commencé
c'est-à-dire que l'Ukraine est en pleine
guerre mais on reconstruit oui si vous
pouvez visiter par exemple le
barradianca et voir les photos des
destructions qu'on a retrouvé une fois
que le village était libéré c'était
avril je pense début avril au fin de
mars et là voir les maisons qui sont
construites à la place ils sont faites
vite et ils sont faites avec les
nouvelles planifications donc sont faits
mieux et c'est aussi tout un enjeu de
reconstruction c'est bon profiter de
malheurs pour faire vraiment mieux donc
il y a beaucoup de spécialistes beaucoup
des urbanistes qui sont engagés de monde
entier pour essayer d'installer les
nouvelles types d'urbanisme les
nouvelles accès aux nouvelles respect
des climats
qui n'existait pas auparavant absolument
pas été appliqué lors de la construction
évidemment les bâtiments de l'époque
chauve évidemment ça c'est clair que non
opportunité exactement
c'est très important aussi parce que les
gens voient que la vie continue et qu'on
n'est pas seuls et qu'on se bat et que
en disant que il faut pas attendre la
fin de hostilités pour commencer à
refaire tout ce qui était défaites et
sinon en revenant à la citation qui
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure effectivement
il y a une énorme demande de justice par
rapport à la Russie et on pense souvent
ça sent on le publie mais vraiment
chaque semaine dans les interviews que
c'est pas aux de pays mais c'est heureux
c'est eux qui ont détruit et c'est à eux
de payer dans quelle Ford absolument
trouver les mécanismes pour ramener tous
ces saisies des avoirs russes qui sont
un peu partout pour les faire travailler
déjà dans leur constructions pour qu'ils
comprennent que là il y a la prix pour
tout et qu'on ne peut pas absolument
sans aucune responsabilité prendre les
responsa s'entendre les responsabilités
détruire tout par autour de quoi donc
c'est très important
dans l'histoire on a fait payer les
vaincus dans l'histoire de la guerre non
mais voilà et d'ailleurs ça a eu des
cons après et d'ailleurs ça a eu des
conséquences
à la Prusse à l'époque la défaite de
Sedan et puis après la guerre de 14h on
va pas refaire toute l'histoire et les
conséquences
parfois vénéneuses de de ce qu'on a fait
payer au 28 mai dans le cas précis
on peut pas imaginer faire payer la
Russie
j'ai du mal à imaginer ce qui pourrait
se passer par exemple si on est dans un
processus négocié ce qui se profilera
peut-être à l'horizon dans quelques mois
ou l'année prochaine si c'est négocié il
y a peut-être ça sert pas partie de la
négociation je pense que les avoir
effectivement qui sont à l'extérieur il
y a sans doute de possibilités selon
quel processus ça je l'ignore mais les
c'est sans doute comme ça que ça se
passera c'est-à-dire que
est-ce qu'il faut que la Russie perde
clairement la guerre pour payer je pense
c'est-à-dire que il faut qu'il y ait une
vraie défaite militaire russe auquel cas
oui mais ce qu'il y aura une vraie
défaite militarus je l'ignore et en tous
les cas ça sera long avant de l'obtenir
c'est mon point de vue
Florent Parmentier l'Ukraine c'est un
grand pays avec des ressources des
richesses naturelles à quel point la
guerre l'affaiblit économiquement on
parle de Produits Intérieurs Bruts il a
chuté de de dans quelle proportion
29% à peu près sur l'ensemble de 2022 29
et quelques donc c'est un peu moins d'un
tiers de la richesse effectivement qui
s'est cassé il y a la destruction des
infrastructures qui sont importantes il
y a eu on se souvient une importante
campagne de bombardements énergétique la
plupart des centrales énergétiques à la
plupart entre une grande partie centrale
énergétique avait été tapé précisément
au moment de l'hiver histoire de tester
un peu la résilience de l'opinion
publique et puis aussi la capacité de
production propre avec un calcul de la
part de la réussite et consiste à dire
nous on construit chez nous nos propres
armes les Ukrainiens dépendent de
l'extérieur pour obtenir leurs propres
armes en haut des Européens des
Américains mais ne pourront le faire à
partir de production locale ce qui veut
dire que le jour où les Américains ou
les Européens avaient la mauvaise idée
d'abandonner l'Ukraine à ce moment là
il serait très difficile pour l'Ukraine
de pouvoir
maintenir la situation dans lequel elle
est donc il y a ce calcul de long terme
qui consiste à dire tant qu'on chez nous
détruisons les infrastructures de la fin
de l'adversaire et je pense que le
calcul le calcul est là c'est un calcul
de long terme mais mais je redis ce
qu'il disait à la réserver sur le fait
de reconstruire des maintenance
c'est-à-dire que enfin ça peut être un
cercle sans fin c'est à dire je
comprends très bien le l'effet
psychologique ce que ça représente pour
les habitants de ces de ces villages
mais un
une infrastructure stratégique par
exemple est-ce que ça sert à quelque
chose de la reconstruire si
potentiellement les Russes la détruise
de nouveau oui à condition évidemment de
pouvoir la sécuriser de pouvoir la
prendre mieux la protéger que la
première mais c'est obligatoire dès lors
qu'il s'agit de reconstruire des
capacités de produire de l'énergie si
vous n'avez pas d'énergie votre économie
ne peut pas tourner or
il y a encore il faut voir aujourd'hui
qu'il y a il y a un besoin d'énergie à
la fois de production et puis même
globalement
globalement donc on est on est dans ce
dans ce défi là on disait que la guerre
était que quelque chose de d'affaire
logistique parmi les logistiques la
capacité à approvisionner le pays en
nourriture en énergie en eau fait partie
des défis qui permettent au front enfin
au front et à l'arrière de tenir et puis
avec un une notion
que moi j'ai pas souvenir d'avoir
entendu lors des conflits précédents qui
est la notion d'écossiles d'impact
environnemental de la guerre on en a
beaucoup parlé là après la destruction
du barrage de carrouska évidemment
l'écocide comme une arme de guerre qui
sont Gomma dans le sujet d'ouverture on
a entendu volody merzelinski alerté sur
selon ses services secrets il y aurait
des menaces contre la centrale nucléaire
des aporidja et est-ce que il se dit je
prends les devants parce que je ne l'ai
pas fait avant la destruction du barrage
enfin j'ai essayé de comprendre pourquoi
cette communication qu'est-ce qu'il y a
je n'y crois pas ça parce qu'en fait
personne a intérêt à ça qu'on fasse
monter ça aux menaces ça mobilise les
occidentaux on sait bien que la peur du
et toujours très présente dans dans nos
esprits et en tous les cas à l'Ouest
c'est très vrai c'est une stratégie de
la part de Vladimir Poutine de grandir
cette menace
qui dit attention il prépare un attentat
contre cette centrale mais les Russes
n'ont aucun intérêt à faire sauter cette
centrale parce qu'en fait derrière c'est
des revenus cette centrale c'est
l'alimentation en électricité de pas mal
de régions dont la Crimée dont le Dombas
c'est la revente d'énergie demain donc
en fait ils n'ont aucun intérêt à
l'interieur et surtout la destruction
serait assez majeure donc je pense que
ni l'un ni l'autre normalement intérêt à
ce que le vrai sujet aujourd'hui de la
centrale c'est effectivement l'eau du
réservoir qui a du BC et donc de
l'alimentation en eau pour refroidir
effectivement les les réacteurs
aujourd'hui c'est ça le sujet
aujourd'hui
on termine là-dessus merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat à lazarella je rappelle le titre
de votre livre gastrope Nouvel Empire
livre publié aux éditions les petits
matins merci encore à bientôt sur sur
public Senn